this video was sponsored by
brilliant.org
hi welcome to this week's episode of
cold fusion
last week we took a look at electric
flying cars and the problems that still
need to be solved then we took a look at
electric aircraft in general
but today we'll be doing a bit of a fun
episode we're going to take a look at
some of the more creative applications
of neural networks
as well as some concerns the idea for
this episode
came to me while i was browsing twitter
i came across some work by justin
pinckney and doran adler
their project turns any photo of a
person into a disney pixar looking
cartoon
i immediately saw potential for such
software and i think it could be a hit
if they could polish it and implement it
into some kind of app
and i just thought it was cool so i
reached out to justin
and we had a discussion about many
things and i'll include portions of the
chat here
let's get into it you are watching cold
fusion tv
[Music]
so first a bit of background the current
generation of neural networks is fairly
new
only being born in 2012 and in that time
we've already seen them change the world
before 2012 the computer science
community thought that neural networks
were a waste of time
then a man by the name of jeffrey hinton
showed them all wrong
i have a full episode on that story if
you're interested
though one of the most recent impactful
developments and what we'll be talking
about today
is the concept of a generative
adversarial network
or gan for short invented by ian
goodfellow in 2014
gans are thought to be the closest thing
that ai has to creativity
and then today one of the you know
things that's really taken the deep
learning world by storm is your
invention of
gans so how did you come up with that
gowns are a way
of doing generative modeling where you
have a lot of training data and you'd
like to learn to produce
more examples that resemble the training
data but but they're imaginary they've
never been seen exactly in that form
before
when i was arguing about generative
models of my friends in a bar something
clicked into place
and i started telling them you need to
do this this and this and i swear it'll
work
and my my friends didn't believe me that
it would work
but i believed strongly enough that it
would work that i went home and coded it
up
the same night and it worked so take you
one evening to implement the first
version of cancer
it i implemented it around midnight
after going home from the bar where my
friend had his going away party
so how does a gan work basically it's a
pair of neural networks that compete
against each other by trying to fool
each other and they both get better in
the process
there are two parts to again a
discriminator and a generator
let's take image generation as an
example the discriminator
learns to tell real images apart from
fake images created by the generator
at the same time the generator uses the
information from the discriminator
to learn how to produce images that the
discriminator is not able to distinguish
from actual images both neural networks
learn together
and get stronger throughout the training
the training usually finishes when the
discriminator classifies a fake image as
a real one
justin explains further the thing that's
discerning between the real and the fake
images
keeps on improving and improving and in
doing so it helps the generator to
improve because it's
pointing out what what the flaws the
images are that it's general that
are being generated and that helps the
generator to improve those
as you can probably imagine this is a
pretty powerful concept
in the ai space anything to do with
creating and not just simply recognizing
and predicting
is probably using again and recently
many tools have become readily available
so there's been massive development and
accessibility
so let's take a look at some
applications to get you up to speed
here's a few things that gans can do
we've covered some of this previously
but many of you are new here
[Music]
gans can do things like animating the
mona lisa
and a more recent example includes
turning line drawings into people
this was recently covered by the youtube
channel two minute papers
how about a game that estimates what
roman emperors probably looked like
2 000 years ago just from their statues
a very interesting tool for historians
i'd imagine
interpolating choppy footage into high
speed slow motion is also a common use
they can also enhance grainy or low
resolution footage to 4k
with high frame rates check out these
enhanced videos from the turn of the
century
absolutely amazing and i think this is a
great use for such
technology gans can also reconstruct
3d models of objects from images or
how about reconstructing an image of a
person's face just by listening to their
voice
in medicine gans have also been used to
generate new molecules for a variety of
protein targets associated
with cancer inflammation and fibrosis
in 2019 these gan generated molecules
were validated experimentally in mice
i'm not sure if this next one is again
but it is very interesting nonetheless
a neural network called jukebox by open
ai can generate songs that don't exist
you give it a portion of a song and it's
going to try and make up the rest
with some interesting results
[Music]
oh
a key moment for gans in the general
public came from nvidia
in december of 2018. it was called
stylegan
it was a leap forward in image
generation and moreover
it was accessible in february 2019
uber engineer philip wang used the
software to create
this person does not exist.com he
himself was amazed
and stated that it was impressive that
stylegan could quote
pick apart all the relevant details of
human faces and recompose them in a way
that's coherent end quote
i think that's objectively true you can
try it for yourself at this person does
not exist.com
every time you refresh it you get a new
picture of a non-existing person
[Music]
in february of 2019 stargand 2 was
released
and it came with higher resolution and
less artifacts
out of style gun 2 came our main story
for today
a concept with the working title
tunification
the idea is that you can upload or take
a photo of yourself or someone else
and the ai will create a disney pixar
version
let's take a look at some behind the
scenes work that justin has been
involved with while developing tunify
what we made in the end was this kind of
tunification which was to take a
you know a real picture of her face and
kind of give it the characteristics of
something that you might see in a
disneyland pixar animated film so you
know like bigger eyes and smaller chin
and like flamboyant hair and that sort
of stuff um
and that's kind of the yes is that sort
of moving beyond the basics of gans
because
you know normally gans just generate
images
from an existing data set but there's no
existing data set of like photorealistic
versions of disney characters you know
this is something that's a little bit in
between a disney character
and a photo of someone's face and so
that somewhere in between is
you know normally quite a hard thing to
achieve with a game because it's not
really
designed to do that but it's built out
of these different
layers which address different
resolutions in the image
so the lower resolution layers are all
in charge of you know
controlling the pose of the head or the
overall
shape there's like the middle resolution
layers which are like the features like
the eyes the shapes of the eyes and the
mouth and the nose
and then the highest resolution layers
in there are all in charge
of controlling the lighting or the
coloring of the image
um so because there's this kind of
control over the different
layers of resolution then you can
actually do a thing where you
combine two different models that you've
trained so they have to be linked like
and that's what we did for this
unification project we took
um one model which is the kind of
standard thing which is the
photoistic face generation model that
got trained by nvidia
and then another model produced from
that um by
someone who i met on twitter called
doran adler and then swap some of those
layers over so we take the
character model which gives you the kind
of big eyes and the
shape of the head which is kind of
characteristic but then preserve
the high resolution layers from the
photoresist model so that
you know things come out looking looking
a bit more like a photo and those kind
of two things combined to give you this
this kind of weird slightly creepy um
real but not real image which is sort of
in between the two
in between those two things if you're
interested with getting started with
neural networks you may be interested
in this episode sponsor brilliant
brilliant is a great online platform and
app
that allows you to actively learn the
maths and science that governs the world
around us they have a few courses on
neural networks
everything from the history of the
technology to how they work
you can take a quiz at every point in
your learning journey i took a course on
the mathematical concept of infinity
just for fun and i found the brilliant
quizzes quite entertaining
so if you're looking to sharpen up your
critical thinking or planning on a
career change
why not do it in a fun way with
brilliant to start learning today
go to www.brilliant.org
cold fusion and the first 200 people
will get 20
off their annual premium subscription
asked justin about what he thought the
future of ai or neural networks will
look like
he's stressed on the point of efficiency
doing more with less
training these things with much less
data than you need so you know just
having thousands of images rather than
hundreds of thousands or millions of
images
um and also making these things more
controllable
or smaller or more efficient and all of
those things
you know are useful for people who
actually want to try and put these to
practical uses because
although the research side you know the
cutting edge side of things is is really
interesting you know a lot of those
things
aren't always necessarily very practical
to use on a website or a mobile app
in may of 2020 nvidia researchers taught
an ai
called gamegan to recreate the game
pac-man
simply by watching it being played this
ai
was trained on 50 000 examples of
pac-man in order to produce a fully
functional version of the game
without a game engine this is impressive
but then once you start comparing it to
the human brain it's pretty terrible
for a human we'd probably need to watch
one or two rounds of playing the game
to understand what's happening and
subsequently recreate the game
fifty thousand examples is way too much
if we could train ais with very little
info
this could be the next big step another
example is nvidia's deep learning super
sampling
this can upscale video games reducing
gpu load so games can run at higher
frame rates
and higher resolution at the same time
super computers
to take a lower res image and then
intelligently build it up to look like a
native
higher res so if you're playing at 1080p
with dlcs set to performance or
quality then the game is actually
running at 540p or 720p respectively and
then intelligently up scaling back up to
1080. for example at native 1080p
this chain-link fence looks a little
ragged but it's obvious what it is
move to dlss 2 though and everything is
much clearer
compared to the native we've actually
gained detail particularly on the fence
and the handrails
and we're still up at 77 fps from the
native 43.
though for this they had to use a
supercomputer to train the ai
later on in our chat we went onto the
topic of deep fakes and the problems
that they present
good evening my fellow americans
faiths has ordained that the men who
went to the moon
to explore in peace will stay on the
moon
to rest in peace for every human being
who looks up at the moon in the nights
to come
will know that there is some corner of
another world
that is forever mankind
yeah so i think it's an interesting
thing and i think the
you know there's a lot of research going
into detecting
the fakes and you know obviously there's
a lot of research into kind of producing
ever more realistic images
and my feeling is those those two things
will be kind of competing forever
in a you know kind of a never-ending
battle that one will get better for a
while and then
the detection methods will get better
and then the generation methods will get
better
and that's probably just going to be the
state of play kind of
forever um and i don't really think
necessarily one is going to win out and
in that sense i feel like
it's just something that people have to
learn to deal with
nvidia has a built-in method of
detecting if an image is real or fake
and other companies are building such
tools for video as well
in the end i think we both agreed that
it will end up to be something similar
to an arms race
[Music]
so there's been a huge amount of hype
and people are really you know
amazed by some of the results i'm really
blown away by things but i think
it's quite easy to to get carried away
with that and not realize that
a lot of them are still quite limited or
you know when you get outside of their
sort of domain of expertise they can
fall over really easily
that you know they put too much faith in
them and they start to make bad
decisions or bad predictions about
things and if you don't really know that
you just have blind faith i think
there's a
you know there's a big trap of just
assuming that it's doing a good job and
not really using
any of your kind of human intuition or
knowledge about
is that really working very well
so that's about it from me so what do
you guys think about neural networks
and gans in particular what was your
favorite application of gans
do you think that gann technology can
bring a lot of positives to the world
or are you more weary of this kind of
technology let me know
in the comments section below thanks to
all of you who supported the channel by
buying the first edition merch
you should be receiving your voice
messages and music shortly
a standard line of merch is still
available if you'd like to see anything
on science
technology business or history
definitely subscribe to cold fusion
there's a lot of interesting stuff on
here next week's video will be on some
research of nanoparticles that dissolve
plaque and arteries
and may stop heart disease my name is
tagogo
and you've been watching cold fusion
[Music]
cheers
you